It's like, you know, you're in America when the Hindu FBI director
tells a deceased Protestant he'll meet him in a pag in paradise
with a Mormon governor
wait, he said that, bro. He literally he literally said this.
This is what he said about
>> to my friend Charlie Kirk. Rest now, brother. We have
the watch and I'll see you in Valhalla. >> How did they
not laugh? That took discipline on their part. Okay. I would
have I think I would have laughed. I think I could have laughed.
Dude, it's that's the director of the FBI. Like, I'm sorry. James
Comey could write like a million different memos on Hillary Clinton
and he would be better than this guy. James Comey was like actually
it's this country is like actually kind of a joke. I I hate to
say it. I hate to say it. Your country kind of a joke. Country
is pretty up. I'm not going to lie to you. Okay. Oh, this is
where I got this is where I got the opening from. Okay, dude.
A Hindu Gujarati Indian guy using Scandinavian pagan heaven to
honor a Midwestern Protestant Christian. Dude, this is like all
of my most recommended tweets, too. The second I heard it, I
watched it before I looked at Twitter. And
before I looked at Twitter, I watched it and I was like, "This
is going to be the like they're going to absolutely like crucify
him for this." Or, you know, cut a blood eagle into him, I guess,
if we're going to use Norse terms. Like, they're going to destroy
him for this. And yeah, I hop on Twitter and every one of my
recommended tweets is like just people on Cash Patel for this
comment. Almost 3 days to find the killer. It was the father
that turned him in. You make cringe comment about Valhalla. Diffi
everybody. I will just be your pay pig. >> It's just >> Ruben
don
>> seen on Facebook. I don't support what happened to Charlie
Kirk, but Charlie Kirk supported what happened to Charlie >> Um
I mean people try to make that comment. It's not like Charlie
Kirk supported violence or something like it's a it's a principal
position. I know a lot of people here don't understand it. It's
like very confusing to them. I get it. I get it. I get it. I
get why principles are confusing to people. Okay. Anyway, there's
like there's a few more. Hold on. Figured out where he meant.
Oh,
I'll see you in Valhalla. I figured out where he went. Valala
village in India. Dude, it this person I thought this person
was like a liberal or a leftist of some kind.
It just everybody gets into maybe not a leftist. I don't know.
They're followed by Lav first and foremost. Maybe not. But damn,
everybody gets in on the anti-Indian racism, dude. It's nuts.
Cash is like the human embodiment of one of those Indian accounts
that post under a Greek statue with a name like European consciousness.
Yes.
Yes. Why would one Christian say this to another giga Christian?
I don't know if Cash is Christian. I didn't get the impression
he was Christian. Cash did out cringe. Dude, that's that's a
little Yeah, Cash. That governor is like thanking God because
the the governor came out and did the we got him the day after
September 11th. If you guys don't remember we got him. That's
the Obama thing when they got Osama bin Laden. And the governor
came out and said we got him the day after September 11th. It
was a little it's like just why why why do these people just
step on mines? Yes. And we're going to cover the press conference
so you'll see it in real time. You'll see it. Bro, it's it's
been a day. It's been a day to say the least. All right. It's
been a day and a half.
My god. All right. Bush. No, not Bush. Obama. Obama came out
and said, "We got him." Ladies and gentlemen, we got him. Bush
got uh Who did Bush get? Got someone else. It was Bush. Wait,
what? Am I crazy? >> Good evening. Tonight, I can report
to the American people and to the world that the United States
has conducted an operation that >> Did he not say it? Did
Obama not say it at all? Different meme? Really? Oh, that's terrible.
I guess it was Bush.
Really? It was really Bush. Oh, Jesus. Hold on. Really? >> Ladies
and gentlemen, we got him.
>> Oh, wow. How does that How does that come into my mind
is like Obama? I don't get it. I don't understand at all. I don't
get it. But it's fine. We continue. We move forward. I'm going
to have a hard time remembering back that far to be honest anyway.
So, you know, it is what it is. I know Trump said he died like
a dog. I know that the ponder monkey. I got it. I got it on that
one. Okay, let's see here. I've got a couple other things I do
want to actually pull up though before we get into the main story.
Okay, >> you guys see this? Anybody see this? This is like
the last thing in the world you want to hear from your president.
Hold on. >> Listen to the question. Listen to the question.
Listen to the answer. >> Radicals on the right as well.
We have >> radicals on the right is right. >> People
have gotten are watching all of these videos and cheering.
Some people are cheering that Charlie was was
how do we fix this country? How do we come back >> I'll
tell you something that's going to get me in trouble, but I couldn't
care less. The radicals on the right often times are radical.
>> You hear that? I couldn't care less. How the do you
say, dude? It's like, how do we bring this country together?
I couldn't care less. I couldn't care >> Back together.
>> I'll tell you something that's going to get me in trouble,
but I couldn't care less. The radicals on the right often times
are radical because they don't want to see crime. They don't
want to see crime. >> My radicals based in awesome. Your
radicals cringe and gay. >> Worried about the border. >> They're
saying we don't want these people coming in. We don't want you
burning our shopping centers. We don't want you shooting our
people in the middle of the street. The radicals on the left
are the problem. And they're vicious and they're horrible and
they're politically savvy. Although they want men and women sports,
they want transgender for everyone. They want open borders. The
worst thing that happened >> radicals on the right as well.
>> It's crazy. It's always He's saying he couldn't care
less. Okay. He's saying he couldn't care less to what's about
to happen. I still think him saying, "Oh, well, the radicals
on my side are fine and the radicals on their side suck." I still
think that's insane. It's baffling. Okay. It's baffling. Your
president has no interest in in healing your country at all.
Your president literally wants to tear your country apart. It's
It's wild. Sorry. When when he says I couldn't care less, he
does mean I couldn't care less to the question. Like that is
the answer. I don't care about sewing or sewing uh sorry healing.
I want to sew division. That's what he wants. He's building a
dope ballroom. I've heard. Yeah, I heard that as well. Mr. President,
how are you holding up? Oh, quite well, actually. We're building
a ballroom here at the White House. Didn't you know? Didn't you
know we're building a ballroom? Oh, god. Okay. All right. What
else we got? We got one other.
Not one other. We got a couple other couple other things here.
Which one do I go to first? This will be I'm going to cover this
later and I might have We'll see if people find anything on this.
I do want to cover a lot more of Asmin Gold's whole like doxing
and cancelling campaign. I do want to actually go and find it.
as these, you know,
uh, you know, like Yas Queen comments that people like her make
on Blue Sky that have absolutely no push back because they're
on their own protected reservation away from anybody whose opinions
could be different than their own. And that's the reason and
also those are the only people that are still left on the platform.
And soon if with enough enough effort and enough work uh we can
have enough of these people uh removed from our uh our media,
removed from our public discourse and uh removed from any sort
of positions of power where they can exercise their completely
uh totally deranged viewpoints and worldview. And so anyway,
I want to let you know that this is definitely not uh the only
amount of them that there are. I'm sure there's plenty more.
And so if you want to
express and show any of these other people and you want to post
one of their uh their comments or anything like that, um I would
recommend anybody to go on >> Still freaking out. No, this
is from last night. This is the same video from last night, but
he's like uh >> Roach Ranch. >> I'm just giving it
for people who didn't catch it last night. Okay. Um, sorry, not
not comment community right here. >> Yes, the guy wanted
to go on ice for fun. Uh, I do not really moderate this out.
And if you guys want to post the
>> dude, it's it's crazy.
It's crazy. And and I believe they've actually gotten some people
fired now. So, that's going to come later. We're not there yet,
but but that we're that is going to come later. Okay. Have to
go through some of this stuff first. Uh, I cut this right before
I went on. I didn't even look at what it was. So, I'm going to
look at what it was. Hold on. Uh, okay. So, I'm going to start
from the top on this one. Okay. There's a Midas touch tweet.
Sorry. Minus touch tweet saying, "Deeply disturbing rhetoric
is spreading from influential manga figures and it's just a bunch
of people calling for war and whatever." Okay. On the right.
All right. And this guy responds, "This is what you need to pay
attention to. There's only one side calling for war. Coincidentally,
that side doesn't acknowledge the political violence against
the left." Masterson quote tweets that and says, "You shot two
of our guys."
And Lykan comes into his replies. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Lyken and Dick
Masterson. Lykan asks, "What's the split between right and left
wing fatal political violence over the last 10 years? Which side
is responsible for more year-over-year and constantly trending
upwards? Also, what was the political ideology of the perp yesterday?"
Uh-oh. So, like asked this. This was last night. Okay. So, he
didn't necessarily know last night. Responds. I'm afraid this
sort of observational comedy is no longer relevant. You guys
one of our guys. So now we get to ram fascism up your ass for
50 years. Thank you for your attention to this matter is just
like, "Yeah, we're going to kill you guys now." Yep. Yep. Yorg.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. We um we looked at this last night. The
charlie's murderers.com. Asmin Gold just wants to set up a site
to dox these people to go after these people to try to get them
fired. It's nuts. He's lost his mind completely. Does Masterson
understand he would die in a civil war near instantly? Lauo,
why say this? Does he understand? I believe he does. He understands.
I think that he wouldn't do well in a civil war, but he I don't
think he gives a I just don't think I don't think he cares, man.
I don't think gives a Yeah, I just don't think he does. Uh yeah,
I just I I thought that was kind of interesting. Kind of funny.
I don't know if like even responded. Yeah. 29 quote tweets from
uh from 29 reposts. Jesus.
Jesus. It's been like this for a while though. Was like this
a while back as well, right? What was his response to um to like
the election? I think his response to the election or Trump getting
shot at was like we're we're just going to put you in crystals.
We're just going to imprison all of you guys. He likes to he
likes to hit that note once in a while. Okay. Just going through
my I I did like a Twitter scrape through before I started. Okay.
>> Dean Dean posted this. Okay. I think I I said about
Dean, I understood why he cried. Maybe I didn't think it was
that cringe. I didn't think it was that bad, but like I I kind
of get why you cried, but I don't understand why you do this.
In response to critics, here's why I cried.
Why the [__] you post this video? This video I will
criticize.
Here's why I cried. Actually, debate me on my tears.
This is like Hunter Avalone. It's a Hunter Avalone tier like
video. Debate me on why I cried. No, just it's fine, dude. The
It's not that big a deal. I promise. It's okay. Hey, you're going
to be okay. In the last 24 hours or so, I've received a lot of
public scrutiny and backlash in response to the fact that yesterday
after Charlie Kirk died, I cried. And then the video of me crying
was blasted all over the internet. So, first and foremost, I
am distraught because of what happened to Kirk. I think that
gun violence is always wrong. And I also think that violence
leads to more violence. In fact, today we've already had three
H.B.CU CUS go into lockdown because of retalatory threats in
response to what happened to Kirk. And that's my position. That's
how I feel. But I'm going to be honest, that on its own isn't
what invoked the extreme and raw emotional reaction of tears
that you guys saw that I'm now being criticized so heavily for.
There's a handful of things that invoked that reaction of mine,
and here they are. The first thing that invoked that reaction
out of me was watching the uplo video of what had happened to
him and how extremely violent it was while then also learning
that his wife and three-year-old daughter were watching from
the crowd. When this occurred, I momentarily placed myself in
the shoes of his wife or three-year-old daughter and how they
had to watch that. And that is like son his wife or three-year-old
daughter.
Okay. I Okay. >> Yes. That made me extremely emotional.
The second reason why I cried is because my best friend Parker
was standing. >> He had a son. I don't know. I He had more
than one kid. I'm pretty sure >> less than 30t away from
him when it happened in person. In fact, he was next in line
to debate Charlie Kirk. And not only the fact that he had to
witness this, but then also then turned around and facetimed
me while he was running away and screaming, not knowing if this
might be a mass casualty event where he or anybody else there
would be next. Was >> Why would you include that? These
guys are just weird with like the amount of honesty they have
on the internet. Why would you include that you were running
away screaming?
You guys have no idea how scary it was. Why? I It It just seems
like a weird thing to be like that o upfront and honest about.
I don't know that it's bad. It's just like odd. Very traumatic
for me and onset a lot of emotions. The third reason why I cried
is because Charlie Kirk is somebody that I've personally interacted
with in real life. Now, the reason why I've personally interacted
with him is because I disagreed with nearly every single thing
he believed in, and I personally let him know. But I'm not good
with gore, and seeing those things happen uh to somebody that
I've personally interacted with in real life was was really hard
on me psychologically.
It's also worth adding on that my tears weren't me telling you
how you should feel, but rather you happening to see me and how
I felt because of everything I've just described in this video
all going through my head at the exact same time in the moment
of >> Okay, I don't I don't know why this had to be made.
This was obvious, by the way, just from the video. Just the video
in the first place was it was obvious this is why he cried. He
literally was like in front of his kids, man. That's so up. And
then he started crying like I Yeah, this was apparent to anyone
who watched, man. You didn't have to do this. This video is just
weird. This is odd.
Think because of blowback by Tik Tok girls who love Charlie's
death. Even so, even so, it's cringe to like plate those people.
It's incredibly cringe. Tell those people to [__]
off. Tell those people to get some humanity, man. Oh, let's see
here. Sorry. Somebody asked me about whether or not this shooter
was a groper. No, the shooter was not a groper. I've seen some
people say that, by the way. I've seen people just like outright
lie about that. I am pretty confident just from the actual evidence
that's released, it's pretty clear what his political ideology
was, we can look a little more into it. Okay, we can look a little
more into it. But I'm I think it's pretty obvious what his political
ideology was. And I I don't think that means very much, right?
Like there would there would be people on the left, there would
be people on the right who would all call for violence and those
people suck, right? Whether or not this person falls on the left
or falls on the right doesn't really matter to me. All right.
Has IRI has some pretty compelling evidence apparently. Of what?
Some compelling evidence of what? I would love to see whatever
the compelling evidence is. Line it up. Line it up for me. Because
he dressed as a Griper meme for Halloween. What's the Griper
meme he dressed as? I I can just tell you
why. Oh, why, dear sir, would he get would he talk with his cousin
or his his family member at some holiday event, okay? talk to
them and they would talk about how they're explicitly
they think Charlie Kirk is bad and pushes hateful rhetoric. Why
would they talk about that? Oh, if we have Discord logs, I'd
love to look at it, but Soapbox, if you can, can I see the evidence?
If you have links to the evidence of that, I would love to see
it. Thinking Groers invented the tracksuit meme. I
would be totally fine saying I believe this guy was a right-winger.
That was that was my bet off the bat. By the way, I've got like
$200 in bets now today that this guy's not a groper. If you want
in on this guys, let's go because I'll I keep I keep betting
people that hey that's not a groper. I'm I'm pretty confident
from the I read. We'll see if it changes. But you if you think
so and you want to make some you want to make some money. Okay.
You think this guy's a groper? You want to bet on it? Go ahead.
Vin, we're on for 50 bucks, right? I believe we're on for 50.
I don't think we have his social media is the only thing. It's
the only strange thing. I was right all along. He was a rebelling
Mormon. Maybe. Is this really the evidence? Let me see here.
Your anon central. Oh, this is not ev
You think cuz this guy thought he he looked at a Pepe. Do you
guys think Gropers own Pepe the Frog? This isn't even a Groper.
A Groper is a specific kind of like Pepe essentially like a specific
kind of frog meme. This isn't even a Groper. This is just a Pepe
the Frog meme. The word of the day is groper. Uh-huh. How are
people this dumb? Dude, this is nuts. This is nuts. No, no, no,
no. I don't, guys. I don't care. Stop talking about what I would
stop talking about how IRI is and post the evidence he has or
stop talking about him. If you guys want to say IRI has some
evidence, just show me what he showed. Give me a clip. Give me
a link. Give me anything, but don't don't just talk about how
he's or something. I don't care about him. Give me the evidence
that anybody has. Are you sure that if this was the evidence
he had, then yeah, then we could start talking about it. Holy
[__] that would be bad. Okay.
All right. What else we got? We got two more things and then
we're on to the Charlie Kirk stuff. Okay, >> we'll watch
the press conference. We'll go through some of this. I thought
this was interesting. It's just a It's Fentes talking about Charlie
Kirk in September 2025 and then a month earlier. Okay, let's
listen. Let's give it a listen. >> We had our disagreements.
Where we did agree is that he would go to these college campuses
and proclaim the name of Jesus Christ. And ultimately, that is
why he was the gunman that killed him. They hated him because
of his defense of Christian morality.
Charlie Kirk cannot call himself a Christian anymore. Sorry,
you forfeited that. I do not want to hear and you cannot allow
Charlie Kirk to go to one more public event,
one more question and answer, one more ask me anything without
being protested, without being shouted down, without being interrogated
about this. This guy goes around from campus to campus in the
most artificial and phony and fake way talking about, "Oh, God,
God made me very blessed that I control $500 million. Oh, I'm
so blessed. I'm so rich and I'm so blessed. And oh, God's been
so good to me. I'm such a Christian. Oh, the Lord I I the Lord
gave me the Sabbath. I take Saturday off." You sit there and
call yourself a Christian and then you make excuses for the genocide
of two million people. O, seriously, you stand there and purport
to be an evangelist like Billy Graham.
Oh, you're the latest Billy Graham. You're our generation's
America's pastor.
Why? Cuz you said the right words. Cuz you said, "God bless.
God bless.
God bless my friend. Oh, I rebuke the devil in the name of Jesus."
And then you go around from campus to campus making excuses for
a famine.
We had our >> So, yeah. I listen, Nick could switch on
this. He could There could be like actual legitimate reasons
for the the flip, right? But I just I I remember this being a
pretty consistent theme of him talking about Charlie Kirk, just
that Charlie Kirk was totally disingenuous. Charlie Kirk was
not a sincere believer. He didn't he didn't really believe in
this guy at all. And
ah,
what are we looking at here? I'm looking I'm just looking to
see if anybody had anything interesting for like evidence in
here. I think it's pretty clear that this guy's like anti-fascist.
He's uh like a leftist like some kind of leftist.
Oh my god. There is one more tweet I wanted to look at as well.
Michael Nolles. Michael Nolles did a big tweet. I think this
is going to be I read the first like paragraph and then I was
like I'll just read it on stream.
Just by which he said last night dudes sees a power vacuum of
this movement. Yeah, there is a there's a massive power vacuum.
A lot of people are going to try to reach to grab it. Okay. And
there's two people that I think are the top media personalities
that have a shot at sort of seizing this space. Okay. One of
them is Nick. The other is Nick's actual mortal enemy. Okay.
Is Ben Shapiro. These are the two people who could like maybe
seize this. No, no, no. These are the only two who could seize
this right now. All right. And Oh, man. Ben Ben talked about
it. I believe Ben is Is did Ben make this? Is this like an official
announcement? I saw the tweet for it. Is this like this is a
ha it's gatafumodor tweet. Is this an official announcement?
>> Because we're Americans and we're not going to be deterred.
Charlie's voice is not silent. We're going to pick up that blood
stained microphone where Charlie left it. >> Oh, right.
Never mind. This is This is Ben saying he's going to keep going
to campuses. Ben's going to go on tour. Ben's going to do some
I don't I don't think this is a Dude, Gatumodor just goes nuts
sometimes. This is Never mind. I have a time stamp for this as
well. when people >> it's somewhere around this last section
and he he says the same thing about the >> he was what
made America great
Robert his possession and may he rest in >> now it's still
up to us >> there we go >> I saw a lot of rumors
online today I was made aware of this by my team that I'm that
I canceled some sort of college tour that's I saw those rumors
they are false I will be coming to college campuses many of them
this year so will we all I am sure because we're Americans And
we're not going to be deterred. Charlie's voice is not silent.
We're going to pick up that bloodstained microphone where Charlie
left it. And to those who would intimidate, who would seek to
stop us, who would seek to end free discussion, who believe
there's less evidence that he's an Antifa leftist than he's a
groper. It's way more likely. No, it's not. There's not. There's
like literally only evidence that he's like a leftist and an
Antifa like person. Antifa is like by far the most obvious thing.
There's just I'm sorry buttsniffer. You'd have to be a complete
[__] to think a groper writes hey catch. Hey fascist
catch on a bullet. You'd have to be so stupid to think that.
Hey fascist catch. They literally idealize fascists. They literally
watch edits like uh aura farming edits. Are you serious? Isn't
that a Hell Divers reference? Uh the Hell Divers reference is
the code for dropping the bomb, I'm pretty sure. But either way,
the Bella Chow thing is obviously um what do you call it? More
Antifa stuff. So, one meme bullet was serious, but the rest were
jokes. No, the Bellachow song is another Antifa thing. Gropers
meme. You're just going to you're just going to cope super hard
about this. Gropers there. You can find one tangential reference
to Gropers and it's like a core theme of the other stuff uh of
being Antifa, of being like a leftist. It's like a core theme.
The best argument that it's a groper and not a leftist is that
it's all diop/me.
Yeah. which is stupid. There's also a bunch of other evidence
here. It's it's it's fine. We'll get more into it. You're saying
Gropers do not in fact meme about that song. I've not seen it.
The bullets could be a Why would you assume SCOP attempt?
What? Okay. Why would we assume SCUP attempt over just actual
genuine belief in some way or even like memeing but stuff he
memes about like stuff he actually likes or cares about. So,
I'm the only Groper expert here. You might be Buttsniff. If you
think you're a Groper expert, show me Nick Fentes playing that
song on his stream. Go ahead. I'll wait. What would be sufficient
evidence for you to say the shooter is a griper? Uh, if you could
find like evidence of him being a groper. You can find like actual
evidence. I'm guessing like guys, there's a there's a of Discord
messages about this, right? There's a Discord messages. We're
going to figure it out. I think we're going to have a real like
a a real actual answer on this. We just have to wait. That's
not actually what my name means at all. A second. And that none
of that's true, but just so you know. I don't know if you know
that. Okay.
All right. All right, the Michael Nolles thing. Dude is alive.
Oh, yeah. He's also alive. We're also going to have him getting
questioned. Yeah, it's not like he's dead. The song is in the
Groper War playlist. The Groper War playlist that gets played
by who? That is made by Who? Cuz Hold on. Did I not pull this
up? I'm pretty sure I've got H playing this song to open his
stream like two days ago. Hold on. Give me a second. Let me go
find this link real quick. Let's see here. I got to go find it.
This is the opening to H's stream a couple days ago.
>> One week ago.
Do we really consider H leftwing? Yes.
H is a leftist. He is a Marxist Leninist. He is a far-left. Yes.
Are you serious? Do we really consider Ha left-wing? The guy
who only writes about hardcore socialist and communist theory?
Yes, we think he's a leftist.
Yes, we absolutely do. Wait, is he still a registered Republican?
I think he's not a registered Republican if I'm if I'm not mistaken.
I'm pretty sure he's not. Wait, the best part of the Aiden Ross
Fentes reaction. Oh, sure. Uh, you're going to it's going to
be a Nick's going to say something about and Aiden's going to
go, "Hey yo, what the man? Yo, I didn't know this guy didn't
like,
>> right? Nihilistic
violence." >> Is we're going to get the Aiden Ross pretending
he doesn't know exactly who Nick Fuentes is. >> And it's
coming from all sides. nihilistic violence perpetrated by
like these opportunists and predators, these young mostly adolescent
black men that are preying upon the innocent and the vulnerable
on city subways, city streets. We see it in the barbarism, the
predatory opportunistic. >> Hold on, butt sniffer. Then
just take the take the bet, bro. Throw down five subs and then
if if he's a groper, if it comes out that he's a groper, I'll
owe you 10 subs back or or 50 bucks. I just PayPal. You throw
down five subs right now, escrow it as the bet. And I'm saying
on stream, if this guy comes out and he's a groper, I send you
$50 back. Throw throw down some money, bro. >> Attacks,
executions. >> Chad, what do you think the solution? >> Cruel
acts of violence.
>> What do you guys think? >> We see it in Zionism.
dare I say in a certain strain of the religion.
>> which says that the people of Palestine are collectively
responsible for the actions of none of them are innocent. They
all must >> Okay, see I'm not with that. >> Members
of Congress like Randy Fine. >> Yeah, I'm not with that.
I'm I'm with the Free Pal, >> by the way. Like I'm just
telling you, okay, people Oh, and you're looking at it on Twitter
today. Everybody's like, "Oh, Vos Bosch is like totally peaceful."
Or sorry, not Bosch. I looked at Vos's thing here. Uh Nick's
like totally peaceful guys >> Palestine are collectively
responsible for the actions of none of them are innocent. They
all must >> Oh sorry he's imitating somebody else here
but there's a bunch of different violent rhetoric in this speech
from last night with that members of Congress like Randy Fine.
>> Yeah I'm not with that. I'm I'm with the free Palestine
>> starving women and children a million people under the
age of 18 being blown to smitherines. >> Not all Jews are
like that chat you know this forcibly don't do that. We see it
in another form which is leftism, communists, anarchists. There
is a certain strain of radical trans. So Matt Slice, I don't
know that I want to bet. I'm just betting like not groper because
there's a bunch of people posting this guy's a griper, a bunch
of people running with that. So I'm just betting not groper.
That's what I'm betting on. If people don't want to bet on that,
that's totally fine with me. Also, this clip sucks. >> Most
are. I agree, chat. Most are >> for them. Everything is
political. Everything is ideological. >> You know, most
are. That's facts. all this propaganda. >> Wait, hold on.
What was this last part?
>> Not all are like that chat. You know this forcibly.
>> Don't do that. I see. >> We see it in another
form which is leftism. Communists, anarchists. There is a certain
strain of radical trans. >> Mostar I agree chat. Most >> what?
Oh, dude. People who sell out their own like ethnic group are
the worst. Like the actual worst. Okay. Wife is supposed to speak
in 8 minutes. Okay. Yeah, sure. Me a link. We'll we'll check
it out. I won't miss it. But dude, the people people like this
are just the worst. Like opportunists who sell their out their
own ethnic group, their own people for like a buck. The absolute
worst people every single time without without a doubt. And you
don't have to like hate other groups. I'm just saying if you
like act like your group sucks to other to people from other
groups who are like racist and you are like the lowest you are
the lowest of the low. It's it's the worst every single time.
I'm not advocating like you should feel like you're supreme.
You can feel like everybody's equal, but just if you act like
your group is worse to a bunch of people who are racist, you're
like, eh, you're you're gross. Aiden is just a Aiden is not that
dumb. Aiden knows what he's doing here. Aiden's not that dumb.
People think he's he's dumb. He's not that dumb. Telling you.
Telling you he ain't that dumb. >> Geeky Candy with the
five. That's uh that's another hour on the stream, guys. Damn.
Monetization rolling in fast tonight. Let's go. Thank you very
much, Geeky Candy. Super appreciate it. Super duper appreciate
it. All right, I'm going to read this tweet and then I'm going
to throw up uh we're probably going to start with the um we'll
probably start with the actual video here. Okay, I don't know
why this starts 12 minutes in, but this will be the this is the
actual press conference from earlier today. We're going to check
this out. We'll check it out for about 8 minutes and then we'll
watch I guess Charlie Kirk's wid widow is going to speak. So,
we'll we'll check that out as well. You ever heard him try to
read? The kid is illiterate. No, he's not. I promise you he's
not. I promise you when he reads when he does that, he is faking
it. I guarantee you he's faking it. Dude's like a a super high
like upper class person whose first connection to the internet
was like playing video games with LeBron's son. He's like he's
not he is not dumb. I just don't believe it. Anyway, you know,
I'm going to save the tweet for later. We'll save the tweet for
after. I'll be right back. >> Good morning, ladies and
gentlemen. We got him on the evening. >> Wait, I won't
be right back. Cringe. Cringe. cringe again. >> Of September
11th, a family member of Tyler Robinson reached out to a family
friend who contacted the Washington County Sheriff's Office with
information that Robinson had confessed to them or implied that
he had committed the incident. This information was relayed to
the Utah County Sheriff's Office and scene investigators at Utah
Valley University. This information was also conveyed to the
FBI.
Investigators reviewed additional video footage from UVU surveillance
and identified Robinson arriving on UVU campus in a gray Dodge
Challenger at approximately 8:29 a.m. on September 10th in which
he is observed on video in a plain maroon t-shirt, light colored
shorts, a black hat with a white logo, and light colored shoes.
When encountered in person by investigators in Washington County
on September 12th in the early morning hours, Robinson was observed
in consistent clothing with those surveillance images.
Investigators
interviewed a family member of Robinson who stated that Robinson
had become more political in recent years. The family member
referenced a recent incident.
>> Okay, this is important right now to knowing the uh
the ideology stuff. is actually important. >> In which
Robinson came to dinner prior to September 10th and in the conversation
with another family member, Robinson mentioned Charlie Kirk was
coming to UVU. They talked about why they didn't like him and
the viewpoints that he had. The family member also >> So
they talked about why they didn't like him and the viewpoints
they had. >> Stated Kirk was full of hate and spreading
hate. The family member also confirmed Robinson had a >> So,
the one thing I will say here is the family member says that
he's spreading hate. It didn't seem like the guy himself said
he was spreading hate. >> Gray Dodge Challenger.
Investigators identified an individual as the roommate of Robinson.
Investigators interviewed that roommate who stated that his roommate,
referring to Robinson, made a joke on Discord. Investigators
asked if he would show them the messages on Discord. He >> uh
Buttsnifa, I'm giving you better than the odds you're asking
for. >> He opened it and showed several messages to investigators
and allowed investigators to take photos of the screen as each
message was shown by Robinson's roommate. These photos consisted
of various messages, including content of messages between the
phone contact name, Tyler. What are the odds? One:1. You're you're
getting the 60 side of your 6040, and I'm doing one to one that
he's not a groper. So, I'm saying if you give if you give five
subs, then if we find out he's a griper, I'll give you I'll give
you 50 bucks back. Pay value. You do whatever. Okay? With an
emoji icon and Robinson's roommates's device. The content of
these messages
included messages affiliated with the contact Tyler stating a
need to retrieve a rifle from a drop point, leaving the rifle
in a bush, messages related to a to visually watching the area
where a rifle was left, and a message referring to having left
the rifle.
>> So, this whole thing is a little confusing to me, okay,
with the with the governor and everything like this. So he's
saying that like the the guy the roommate is showing him screenshots.
Is the governor saying that the roommate was coordinating with
him? Because like listen to the screenshots that the roommate
is showing. >> And Robinson's roommates's >> so he
so the the investigators meet up with Robinson's roommate and
they say the roommate shows them messages on his device like
from a text, right? The roommate was supposed to pick up the
gun. Sounds like >> the content of these messages
included messages affiliated with the contact Tyler stating a
need to retrieve a rifle from a drop point, leaving the rifle
in a bush, messages related to a to visually watching the area
where a rifle was left, and a message referring to having left
the rifle wrapped in a towel. The messages also refer to engraving
bullets and a mention of a scope. So like why is he telling his
roommate,
"Hey, I'm leaving this gun over here. Hey, is it messages directly
or messages in a Discord server?" There's screenshots. Okay,
maybe. Hold on. Maybe there screenshots. Wait, >> leaving
the rifle? >> Let me Let me roll it back. Actually, hold
on. Let me I I'll because we're going through this. I believe
Steven Crowder is the one who This is him reading directly from
the police report. Steven Crowder posted the police report. This
is the same thing, right? Investigators identified an individual
as the roommate of Robinson. Investigators interviewed the roommate
who stated that his roommate, referring to Robinson, made a joke
on Discord. Investigators asked if he would show them show them
the messages on Discord. He opened it and showed several messages
to investigators and allowed investigators to take photos of
the screen as each message was shown by Robinson's roommate.
These photos consist of various messages including content of
the messages between the phone contact named Tyler with an emoji
icon and Robinson's roommate's device. So like this is I don't
know what this means. Including content of messages between the
phone contact. So it sounds like he also took screenshots of
their phone messages, right? I don't know but it should be pretty
obvious but whatever. Um to visually watching. Sorry. I'm not
going to deal with the bet anymore. Either take the bet or don't.
So, the content of these messages included messages affiliated
with the contact Tyler from his phone stating or stating the
contact Tyler, so Tyler Robinson stating a need to retrieve a
rifle from a drop point, leaving the rifle in a bush, messages
related to visually watching the area where a rifle was left,
and a message referring to having left the rifle wrapped in a
towel. Right. So, the messages also refer to engraving. So, it
sounds like he is sending messages to somebody. He is literally
coordinating with somebody that he's doing this. He's talking
to somebody about doing this, right? It sounds like his roommate
suspect accessed Discord on their device and Robinson's roommate's
device. No, it's like phone contact named Tyler as in the person
named Tyler. And this is like text messages from him and his
roommate. Between him and his roommate,
too. So, he's sending screenshots of his messages with Tyler
to his roommate. Not Tyler. Wait, what? Shown by Robinson's roommate.
The These photos consist of various messages including content
including content of messages between the phone contact named
Tyler with an emoji icon and Robinson's roommate's device.
Wait, but Tyler Tyler is the guy? What are you talking about?
Tyler's literally the guy. Tyler is the guy. Is Tyler Robinson?
So like I'm saying it sounds like at minimum he was coordinating
with somebody. So there's somebody else they have to talk to.
But was he coordinating with the roommate? Are they like basically
saying he was coordinating with the roommate? I that's what's
crazy to me is it seems like they're they're openly saying this
this guy was like possibly asking somebody to like stating a
need to retrieve a rifle from a drop point right now. If you
guys remember this does sound a little bit like do you guys remember
the guy who his parents and like lived with them in their house
and like set up like the candles and the ritual and stuff and
had like a video camera. Do you guys remember that thing we covered?
It does sound like a little bit there are like echoes of that.
I'd like to see what happens when they actually interview people
and see what was going on cuz I've heard people mention 764 in
relation to this. I I would need like a decent amount of evidence
evil Johnny Bravo, but I'm going to be pretty good faith about
it. Yeah, we'll check it out. Jun arc. I know about that. I know
about that video. We're going to watch it in just a little bit.
Yeah, dude. This this is like it's I don't know. It's crazy to
me. Anyway, the governor just talks through it >> stating
a need to return a rifle from a reading through it slowly. leaving
the rifle in a bush. Messages related to a to visually watching
the area where a rifle was left and a message referring to having
left the rifle wrapped in a towel. The messages also refer to
engraving bullets and a mention of a scope and the rifle being
unique. Messages from the contact Tyler also mentioned that he
had changed outfits. I know there's been speculation as well
as to uh the the writing on those casings,
those those uh those bullet casings
and uh I believe we have that as well. >> Okay. So, the
governor now is going to read through the casings the share that
you casing etchings. So, the area north of Campus Drive Road
where the suspect crossed over. You saw some of that in the video
that we released last night consists of a grassy area with trees
on the edge of the UVU campus. Investigators discovered a boltaction
rifle wrapped in a dark colored towel. The rifle was determined
to be a Mouser model 98 300 6 caliber 306 caliber boltaction
rifle. The rifle had a scope mounted on top of it. Investigators
noted inscriptions that had been engraved on casings found with
the rifle. Inscriptions on a fired casing read notices bulges
capital o.
What's this question mark?
>> So, this is a well-known like pseudo furry meme. Okay.
It's like a gay furry meme. I didn't think it was like totally
a furry meme only. It seems to have mostly been taken by the
furry community. Okay. Know your meme with the helpful assist
here. Notice his bulge. Oh. Whoa. What's this? This is the original
meme referenced by Tyler Robinson, Charlie Kirk's alleged shooter.
That's some gay furry texting. Okay. Gross. Gross. Gross. >> Inscriptions
on the three unfired casings read, "Hey, fascist exclamation
point. Catch exclamation point.
Up arrow symbol, right arrow,
and uh symbol, and three down arrow symbols."
>> So that is up, right, down, down, down. That is what
is it? It's um it's hell divers for like it's a hell divers's
like input for dropping bombs apparently. So apparently this
guy's a >> Second unfired casing red >> the 500 kg
bomb. The max size bomb. Okay. Okay. Okay. Got it. Got it. >> Bella
Chow. Bellachow. Bellachow. Chow chow. And a third unfired casing
red. If >> So that is the anti-fascist song that we've
been playing a couple times on stream today. >> Read this.
You are gay. >> Hold on. Let's watch him read that one
O Bellachow. Bellachow. Bellachow.
And a third unfired casing read. If you read this, you are gay.
L M A O.
>> I just I just uh Dude, oh, there's a fantastic seven
meme here, isn't there? There's Dude, you do a seven meme, but
the box is like the shell casing. It's like Brad Pitt's like,
"What's in the box? What's in the box?" And then he goes and
looks and it's like, "If you read this, you're gay." He walks
over and shoots Tyler in the head. Okay,
that's that's the meme. We needed that meme. Okay, seven. You
guys all know what I'm talking about, right? What's in the box,
man? Then he reads it. He's devastated. We are indebted to law
enforcement uh across the state who's worked seamlessly together,
local law enforcement, state law enforcement, and our federal
partners with the uh with the Federal Bureau of Investigation.
We're grateful for everyone who worked together in uh in in such
a short amount of time to uh to find this person
and to uh and to bring justice. I want to thank the public who
has been so engaged reviewing uh reviewing videos, re helping
us with uh sending in tips and uh helping us get to this point.
I want to thank uh the uh the family members of Tyler Robinson
who did the right thing in this case and were able to uh to bring
him into. >> So again, this is the big thing, okay, is
they had this guy was I believe this guy was basically in the
wind.
This guy like might have actually totally gotten away. He was
he was basically in the wind and the family called it in. Although
I don't think he would have been in the wind for long with the
messages he put out as well. But dude, okay. All right. I didn't
get this one before. See you. We'll see you in Valhalla, buddy.
Uh-huh.
This is not as good as this is not as good as the Norse memes,
but thank you. Okay. All right. >> To uh to law enforcement
as well. I especially
want to thank the family of Charlie Kirk, uh Erica,
um Charlie's parents, his children. I want us to be thinking
of them as we bring justice in this case. Um they will be involved
in that justice. Uh we will be working very closely with them
as we move through this process as well. This is a a very sad
day for again for our country. Uh a terrible day for the state
of Utah. But I'm grateful that at this moment we have an opportunity
to bring closure to this very dark chapter in our nation's history.
With that, I will now turn the uh turn the microphone over to
the director of the FBI, Cash Patel. >> Oh god. Oh no,
not this guy. >> Thank you, Governor. >> I don't
think he turned himself in. Bub rub. I think so. Some Castle
just said in in uh Twitch chat that
dad talked to his local church minister. I don't know if that's
true. I didn't hear that. I heard that his dad turned him in.
His dad is like a sheriff and his dad turned him in from was
what I understood. But did the dad turn him into like a mandatory
reporter and then the mandatory reporter reported or >> This
is what happens when you let good cops be cops. >> Is it
I don't I don't know, man. >> The FBI and our partners
are proud to stand here today together to bring justice to the
family of Charlie Kirk. >> Wait, if the pastor went to
the
then who gets the $100,000 reward? Who gets the money? >> And
honor his memory. I want to express my deep gratitude to President
Trump, the vice president, and the entire White House who have
been so incredibly supportive with both resources and just personally
the FBI as a team. They had our backs the entire way. And I >> uh
somebody find me a video or an article explaining what happened
with the um with what hap what happened with the kid. >> I
just want to express my gratitude for giving us the resources
we need to operate in this space to bring this sort of justice
at this sort of speed. In 33 hours, we have made historic progress
for Charlie. Governor Cox,
our partnership has been absolutely incredible these last few
days. Our partnership will endure. Your state and local partners,
your sheriffs, your DPS community has been unbelievably impressive
in the hardest of times. And a case like this cannot be solved,
cannot be brought without partnering with your state and local
authorities. the FBI has a certain role to play and we will play
that role. Um, and we will lead out for the federal government.
>> Dude, this guy is like so and the worst part of this
for me is about is it's coming up. This guy actually goes into
like goes into like he he he
just talks about how much money they spent looking for this guy
and totally failing. Like that's all he does for the next like
five minutes. He just talks about all of the money they spent
flying like evidence all over the place and how they got nothing
and that's it. That's all they did. >> But Governor Cox,
we are so grateful for your state partnership that led out on
this investigation. A little bit of the timeline. Charlie was
shot at 12:23 p.m. on Wednesday. The first FBI agents on arrived
on scene in 16 minutes with chiefs of police at 12:39
and secured the scene. The FBI immediately launched fixedwing
assets.
We utilize these assets to transport personnel, specialty technicians,
hostage rescue teams. We also utilize these assets to go back
and forth from the east coast and here in Utah to transport forensic
evidence. >> Guys, we flew back and forth so many times
you don't even know. Uh I've got I've got links to this guys,
but thank you. Thank you very much. Cile, thank you. Um who else
linked? Lui, thank you. Oh no, Cassil and someone else, but thank
you very much. I've got the the links that are explaining this
now. Thank you guys. evidence and other evidence that will be
analyzed and is being analyzed at our FBI laboratories in Quantico
and other laboratories including the ATF. At my direction, the
FBI released the first set of FBI photos of the suspect at 10:00
a.m. local time on 9/11.
Then shortly thereafter, the FBI reward of 100. >> He also
just keeps saying 9/11 instead of September 11th or like on the
11th. Like I just
I it's like doesn't even mean anything. It's just one of those
things where like everything this guy does cuz he's so incompetent.
Everything he does irritates me. >> Was released at 10:45
a.m. local. Myself and Deputy Director Bonino arrived on the
scene at approximately 5:30 p.m. on 9/11. The governor led a
press conference last night at approximately 8:00 p.m. where
at my direction the FBI released a never-before-seen video of
the suspect. We also released
new images to the public of the suspect.
And just last night, the suspect was taken into custody at 10
p.m. local time. In less than 36 hours, 33 to be precise,
thanks to the full weight of the federal government and leading
out with the partners here in the state of Utah and Governor
Cox, the suspect was h apprehended in historic time period.
And I want to highlight what Governor Cox >> how like
what lead led to any of this. Yeah. He he just keeps talking
about how the great police work led to this guy getting captured.
No police work is getting captured helped this at all. Like there's
just nothing.
Hold on. TPUSA channel. I saw somebody say this, but I didn't
Hold on. TPUSA
YouTube. You realize like as much as you guys want to watch this,
you realize this is going to be like um this is going to be awful,
right? You all know that. I would the media, >> but you
all know that it's going to suck, right? It's just going to be
her. It's not going to be good. But we'll watch it. >> And
you the public. That's why we went so public so fast and we're
so transparent and we're committed to that transparency. The
crime scene just a little bit there. It is a large crime scene.
State and local authorities along with federal authorities process
that crime scene quickly and I even had the um ability to walk
through that crime scene and walk through the steps the suspect
took to learn more about what was needed and what resources.
And did you use your your like lifetime of experience as a podcaster
and failed a public defender to figure out what those steps meant?
What the is the purpose of you being anywhere near this cash?
Go sit in DC, you loser. >> We need to prayer to create
a full picture for the FBI and leadership back in Washington.
Furthermore, thankfully to state and local partners, forensic
evidence has been seized and continues to be garnered. Forensic
evidence has already been evaluated at FBI laboratories in Quanico
and state local authorities here. We will continue to process
evidence as we see it as we collect it and we will continue to
>> Yeah. You know what I want the timeline on? I want the
timeline on how this tweeted multiple times that they had the
suspect in custody. How the did you do that cash? Can I get the
timeline on those tweets >> delivered to Governor Cox and
his team last night? We had a total of approximately 7,000 interviews.
Excuse me, 7,000 leads. As of this morning, thanks to your great
work, we have over 11,000 leads that were called in to the FBI,
and we are running out every single lead that we can. Every one
of those leads will be run out. The arrest is a testament to
the dedication of good law enforcement being great and partnerships
in law enforcement, which I've tried to highlight as my tenure
at the director of the FBI. >> By good law enforcement
being great, he means like the dad was a sheriff and technically
the dad was the person who found him and turned him in. So, you
know, yeah, there >> 11,000 leads that lead to nothing.
Cool. >> There is no better relationship for law enforcement
than the FBI to partner with state and local authorities. And
you've seen it here in these last few days. The FBI Salt Lake
Field Office along with our offices in LA, Phoenix, Denver, San
Antonio, Las Vegas, Pittsburgh, Buffalo, our headquarters component
in Quanico all participate in the FBI. I want to express my deep
gratitude to the employees
of the FBI, the men and women, the evidence response team, tacticians,
the special operators, the agents, the support staff.
You have done monumental work in historic time when the public
who had a right to demand such an expeditious solving of an investigation.
The FBI answered that call diligently. >> Dude, I >> critically
important to our nation.
They did not answer the call. They didn't answer the call at
all. You failed
>> And we delivered. And I'm proud to be their leader and
I'm proud to be the director of the FBI. This is a very much
an ongoing investigation, as the governor said, and we will continue
to work with state and local authorities uh to develop the investigation,
to provide them the evidence they need for their ongoing prosecutions.
and we will be here to answer every call they absolutely have
as long as it takes for as long as we need to find and apprehend
whatever suspects were involved in this crime. Lastly, to my
friend Charlie
>> No cash. No, don't address Charlie >> Rest now,
brother. We have the watch and I'll see you in Valhalla. >> Now,
I just want to appreciate Okay, there are some real heroes for
this clip. Okay,
there are some real heroes in this clip. This guy is not laughing.
Governor Cox not laughing.
Whoever this tall guy is not laughing. How the they're not laughing
is beyond me. The superhuman self-control it must have taken
to not laugh this off the stage here is incredible.
So, shout out to the real heroes of this investigation. These
guys who didn't humiliate Cash Patel off the stage. They managed
to hold the laughter in dude. Yeah,
Mr. Governor Cox. It's particularly difficult for him. Okay.
His lips are pressed together so hard he's probably biting his
lip. Might be biting his tongue. You You ever You know, you bite
your lip, you bite your tongue. I often try to like crush my
own toe into the ground to see if I can make that hurt enough
to not laugh. Deep breath. Deep breaths, guys. Thank you. And
good morning. I would just like to take a few minutes
as as the sheriff to express my gratitude for everybody. Okay,
before we go to this guy, I've got uh
Oh, they went live on Charlie Kirk's thing. It's an empty chair.
They did this earlier, the empty chair for his video earlier.
I I can't imagine this will be good. Okay, we'll we'll maybe
go back to it after a little while, but we can check it out after.
I was just going to read one of these articles that's talking
about how the manhunt ended. Okay, so let's check this out. Tyler
Robinson. All we know about the suspect in Charlie's shooting
and how he was caught. Suspect has been named after Donald Trump
said he had been he had been turned in by somebody that was very
close to him. The right-wing influencer 31. Oh, sorry. The suspect
in the shooting of Charlie Kirk is in police custody after two-day
manhunt. The right-wing influencer, 31, was fatally shot on Wednesday
afternoon while speaking at an event on Utah Valley University
campus in Orum. The suspect has been named as Tyler Robinson,
a 22-year-old man from Utah, and the governor's office has released
a photo of him in custody. Here's what we know about him so far.
How was the suspect caught? Utah Governor Spencer Cox said a
member of Robinson's family reached out to a friend who then
contacted the Washington County Sheriff's Office with information
that Robinson had confessed to them or implied that he had committed
the incident. NBC News reports that the family member is his
father and that the father then went to a church minister he
knew who contacted a local sheriff. Donald Trump told Fox News
the father convinced the son to hand himself in, adding that
they then drove into the police headquarters and he's there now.
The father realized his son may have been involved after seeing
images released by the FBI.
Mr. Cox said the family member told the FBI that Robinson had
become more political in recent years and that at the dinner
prior to the shooting, he had mentioned Mr. Kirk's upcoming visit
to Utah Valley University. Utah's governor said that they had
talked about why they didn't like him and the viewpoints that
they that he had and that the family member also stated Kirk
was full of hate and spreading hate. Now, this is the other family
member. It's not necessarily Tyler saying that. He went on to
say that messages from Tyler Robinson seen by his roommate revealed
details about the alleged plot. The content of these messages
included messages affiliated with the contact Tyler, stating
a need to retrieve a rifle from a drop point. Yeah, we've read
all of this. Okay. Mr. Cox added there's no evidence to suggest
anyone was else was involved, but that the investigation was
ongoing. He said the suspect was taken into custody in Washington
County in southern Utah around three a 3 to 4 hour drive from
Orum where his family lived. What else do we know about Robinson?
Oh yeah. So apparently this guy was like he just tested off the
charts. He was like super high IQ.
It's crazy. Sky News has now verified what appear to be school
records posted in 2020 by his mother which show a 4.0 average,
a very high score akin to a straight A's in the UK. This boy
is a genius. She added NBC reports that he is a third-year student
in the electrical apprenticeship program at Dixie Technical College
in St. George, Utah. A spokesperson for Utah Valley University
said he attended the university for one semester in 2021. Family
neighbor Kristen Schwarman describes Robinson as smart, quiet,
and said he never caused any problems. What weapon did he use?
Okay, we've done all of this. We don't need any more of this.
Okay, perfect.
let me see. We get anything going here. I think this is just
going to be like a eulogy. And while that's fine, I just don't
really have any interest in a eulogy to be honest with you. So,
you guys, if you guys want to watch that, you can find it. It's
uh it's there through Turning Point USA. And if there's anything
interesting, we'll get back to it after. IQ means all the indices
scores are going to be more relevant. I don't even know what
that means. The indices scores. Okay, let's keep watching this.
Played a part in this investigation.
>> As you know, I'm going to pull this back just a little
bit here to this guy walking up to the podium. >> Take
a few minutes as as the sheriff to express my gratitude for everybody
who has played a part in this investigation.
As you know, it's been a vast, a complicated, and a very, very
fast-paced investigation. You're looking at people standing up
here who are running on if they got an hour's sleep in the last
couple days, they're probably lucky. Uh, >> this is not
the dad sheriff. They They're not going to let the dad speak
at the governor's press conference. >> Um, it has been
very taxing.
It has been so impressive
speaking on behalf of the local law enforcement to see the cooperation
that we've seen in this type of case. Uh across the state, sheriffs,
chiefs,
um our our state partners have stepped up and have come to the
call on anything that we needed. Uh our county chiefs have been
phenomenal.
our Utah County Attorney, Jeff Gray, who's standing up here with
us, has been phenomenal in leading us through this
>> No, that's not his dad. It's a different It's a totally
different guy. Not his >> I would like to thank the federal
government for for their resource resources, their assets. Our
local team here, our FBI team has been extraordinary in helping
us work through this and bring this person to justice. Most of
all, I would like to thank the public and specifically
I would like to thank the public who turned to prayers and who
turned to positiveness for us. I would like to thank them on
behalf of the law enforcement community because we needed those
prayers. That's what we needed to get through this. We needed
your support and you gave it to us. We needed your patience and
you gave it to us. And I would like to thank you for the Kirk
family because that's what they need is your support and your
prayers and that will get us through all of this. So, thank you
everybody for everybody that have stepped up. We've had such
a phenomenal response to this. Thank you.
>> I also want to give a special thanks to the attorney
general and the Department of Justice, their unwavering support
and their commitment.
>> This is me clicking on the Erica Kirk
>> Vice President Vance and his phenomenal wife Usha for
their love and support. >> I'm sorry, man. If you guys
want to watch this, like, go watch it. I can already tell it's
going to be I can already tell it's not going to be
>> I'm sorry. I just don't I don't >> meant to justice.
>> I'd rather just cover what like actually happened. I
understand that she's going to be upset and she's going to ulogize
her husband. It's totally fine. Okay. >> Here. And without
A.G. Bondi and Deputy Attorney Todd Blance and the resources
they brought to bear, we would not have been able to complete
our mission. And I just want to say special thanks. It's an honor
to be a part of the Department of >> Thank you again uh
to our incredible law enforcement team who has worked so hard.
Um Sheriff, I got a solid 90 minutes last night, so I'm probably
the most well-rested person up here. Ladies and gentlemen, I
uh I get the microphone. So, uh I hope you'll permit me a moment
just to share a few more thoughts about where we are and how
we got here and and uh and maybe a little bit of where we go
from here. Um I I don't want to get too preachy, but I think
it's important that we with eyes wide open understand what what's
happening in our our country today.
I' I've heard I've heard people say, "Well, why are we why are
we so invested in >> Oh, no. I don't know. I'm not going
to be a huge fan of this, am I? There's violence happening all
across our country and violence is tragic everywhere and every
life taken is is a child of God um who deserves our love and
respect and dignity. This is uh this is certainly about the uh
the tragic death assassination political assassination of of
Charlie Kirk. Um but it is also much bigger than an attack on
an individual. It is an attack on all of us. It is an attack
on the American experiment. is it is an attack on our
This cuts to the very foundation of who we are, of who we have
been, and uh and who we could be in better times.
Political violence is different than any other type of violence
for for lots of different reasons. one because in the very act
that Charlie championed of expression that freedom of expression
that is enshrined in our founding documents in in having his
life taken in that very act
makes it more difficult for people to feel like they can share
their ideas that they can speak freely. We will never be able
to solve all the other problems including the violence problems
that people are are worried about if we can't have a clash of
ideas safely and securely even especially especially those ideas
with which you disagree.
That's why this matters. so much over the last 48 hours. I have
been as angry as I have ever been, as sad as I have ever been.
And um it was uh as as as anger pushed me to the brink. It was
actually Charlie's words that pulled me back. I'd like to >> I
dude I don't care like I how do I put this? I'm fine with these
guys like mostly like being but this is >> feel like these
things should be separated a little bit but >> share some
of those and specifically right now if I could I I need to talk
to the young people in our state in my state and and all across
the country as President Trump reminded me he said you know who
who really loved Charlie the youths and he's right um young people
love Charlie and young people hated Charlie and Charlie went
into those places anyway
and these are the words that have helped me Charlie said when
People stop talking, that's when you get violence. He said the
weak, >> man, I kind of got proven wrong on that. He was
talking the whole time. He was talking the whole time. He didn't
really stop talking. >> Can never forgive. Forgiveness
is the attribute of the strong. The only way out of the labyrinth
of suffering is to forgive. Welcome without judgment. Love without
condition. Forgive without limit. He said, "Always forgive your
enemies. Nothing annoys them so much." A few months ago, I referenced
this last night. Charlie posted to social media. When things
are moving very fast, and people are losing their minds, it's
important to stay grounded. Turn off your phone, read scripture,
spend time with friends, and remember internet fury is not real
life. It's going to be okay. He again said, when you stop having
a human connection with someone you disagree with, it becomes
a lot easier. >> If you thought about touching grass, >> fear
to commit violence. He said, "What we as a culture have to get
back to is being able to have a reasonable agreement. Being able
to have reasonable agreement where violence is not an option."
Now again to my young friends out there, you are inheriting a
country where politics feels like rage. It feels like rage is
the only option. But through those words, we have a reminder
that we can choose a different path. Your generation has an opportunity
to build a culture that is very different than what we are suffering
through right now. Not by pretending differences don't matter,
but by embracing our differences and having those hard conversations.
I I think we >> I feel like these guys agreed that they
were going to they were basically like going to give an update
on the investigation. Then they're like, "No, we could do we
could do like five minutes each for a monologue while we have
the limelight." I'm just like kind of done. >> Need more
moral clarity right now. I hear all the time that words are violence.
Words are not violence. Violence is violence.
And there is one person responsible
for what happened here. And that person is now in custody and
will be charged soon and will be held accountable. and and yet
all of us have an opportunity right now to do something different.
I I want to thank my fellow Utons. Uh you know this bad stuff
happens. Um and uh for for 33
>> I was I was praying that uh that um if this had to happen
here that it wouldn't be one of us that somebody drove from another
state, somebody came from another country. Sadly that that uh
that prayer was not answered the way I had hoped for just because
I thought it would make it easier on us if we could just say
hey we don't do that here. Um and indeed Utah is a special place.
We lead the nation in charitable giving. We leave the nation
in service every year. Um, but it did happen here. And >> I
got to imagine Utah's got to be close to the bottom of like um
actual gun deaths per capita or something, right? Like homicides
per capita. Utah's got to be either at the bottom or in like
the bottom five almost certainly. >> It was one of us.
But I I want you to look at how Utons reacted the last two nights.
There was no rioting. There was no looting. There were no cars
set on fire. There's no violence.
There were there were vigils and prayers and people coming together
to share the humanity and and that ladies and gentlemen I believe
is the answer to this. We can return violence with vi violence.
We can return hate with hate. >> Utah number nine, Vermont
first, New Hampshire second, Maine third, Massachusetts four,
Idaho, Hawaii, Wyoming, Iowa, Utah, Nebraska.
These are the lowest homicide rates. And that's the problem with
with political violence is it metastasizes
because we can always >> sorry gun homicide rates >> finger
at the other side and at some point we have to find an offramp
or it's going to get much much worse. But see these are choices
that we can make. History will dictate if this is a turning point
for our country. >> Get him off. Get him out. Get him out.
Boo this man off the stage. Boo this man off the stage. Boo him
off. Get him out of here. >> But every single one of us
gets to choose right now if this is a turning point for us. He
did it twice. He did it twice.
I can't, dude. I Hold on. There's
>> No, there's no way he did it again. There's no way.
Eric Kirk is speaking right now. That's cool. Go watch Erica
Ker speaking. >> We get to make decisions. We have our
agency. And I desperately call on every American, Republican,
Democrat, liberal, progressive, conservative, MAGA, all of us
to please, please, please follow.
>> I'm gonna watch. Hold on. Actually, you know what? I
am going to You guys want it? You guys want this? I'm going to
go watch her speak and I'm going to talk about how boring and
stupid this is the whole time. So, good luck. >> We'll
never surrender. We never will. Ever. Ever. >> We'll never
surrender, guys. >> Our campus tour this fall will continue.
There will be even more tours in the years to come. America Fest
here in Phoenix this December will go on. It will be greater
than ever. The radio and podcast show that he was so proud of
will go on. And in a world filled with chaos, doubt, and uncertainty,
my husband's voice will remain
>> and it will ring out louder and more clearly than ever,
and his wisdom will
>> My favorite my my favorite too, but my husband's favorite
word in the English language was earn. He would call all of you
to be people of action who earn
the future America deserves. So to all of the young people who
felt inspired by my husband's faith in hard work, all of you
already know what Charlie >> Man, I'm so psyched that we
switched to >> You know, if you're in high school or if
you're in college, >> go find your local Turning Point
USA chapter. Join it. >> Like we don't we don't agree with
the politics. They're going to keep the thing going. I We could
just watch any any actual decent information. We could just go
to But it's just like I >> What Charlie taught me. >> Time
to shell. No, it's not time to show. We've got lots of money.
I I'll just I'll just conclude with uh with words I share often
from a author you've all live in who was asked if he was optimistic
about our country and uh he said I'm not optimistic. Oh, by the
way, nothing he's saying is bad. He's just yapping a lot. He's
yapping a lot when it's like super easy. People will lose your
message. Nobody understands that you can be concise. Like figure
out what you want to say and be concise. These people can't be
concise. They just want to yap for like 20 minutes. They just
don't want to be off the stage. That's what I'm annoyed with.
said, "I hate optimism." God, that sounds bad. But he said, he
said, "Poptimism is a vice. It's this idea that good things are
just going to happen." And he said, "In the history of the world,
good things have never just happened." He says, "I'm not optimistic,
but I am hopeful." And >> hope is the virtue that sits
between the vices of optimism and pessimism. Hope is the idea
that good things are going to
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. Why is cash look like that back
there? Bro, cash is just dude. He's he's in over his head >> because
we can make them. So, I still believe in our country and I know
Charlie Kirk believed in our country. I still believe that there
is more good among us than evil. And I still believe that we
can change the Listen, yes, she owns half the organization, but
we're going to have to sit through like 40 minutes of her crying
and and waxing lyrical about her husband, which is fine if you
want to watch that, but it's going to be for me cuz I don't think
her husband was a good person, right? I think it's horrible he
died, but I don't think he's a good person. I'm not going to
sit there and hold my tongue and pretend he was a good person.
Okay, I'm not going to do that. So, I'm just not going to watch
it. If you want to watch it and you care about that, otherwise
I'll just wait for somebody to sum up with a tweet or a clip
what she is going to say the future of TPUSA is going to be,
I just wait for that. The course of history, I'm hopeful because
Americans can make it so. Ladies and gentlemen, we're happy to
answer any questions you may speak to whether the suspect is
speaking with authorities and his
I cannot speak to that right now.
>> How do you interpret the engravings on >> Well,
I will leave that up to you to interpret what those engravings
mean. Um I I think the the clearest one that says catch fascist.
There's not And by the way, that's like catch like a ball, catch
this. Um that's uh I think that that speaks for itself. >> Do
you cover how wrong Paul was again? Yeah. I mean, the fact that
he was uh like that they tried to find like four different trans
people to blame it on was pretty embarrassing for them. Yeah.
>> See, the prosecutors are seeking the death penalty.
The death penalty is only interesting to me if they can't charge
down the line. Cuz if they're going to seek the death penalty
for this guy, I feel like he's he's got a decent shot at getting
away. Honestly, they seek the death penalty. He's got a decent
shot at getting away. If they can't charge down the line, if
they can charge down the line, then it doesn't matter.
>> There there's nothing more that we can share at this
time. >> Governor, you indicated that you've been communicating
with a friend on Discord about the gun. Do you anticipate any
more arrests? >> Uh, we do not at this time have any information
that would lead to any additional arrests. >> You believe?
>> Yes, but the investigation is ongoing.
>> How he came into custody of police and where he is right
now? >> Uh, yes. So, right now, Mr. Robinson has been booked
into the Utah County Jail. Uh, you you heard the president this
morning uh report that uh that he was taken into custody that
uh that his family and uh and a friend um helped to to deliver
him in to the the into custody of law enforcement in Washington
County. Those of you that don't know where Washington County
is, it is the southern most southwestern most part of the state
of Utah. It's about a three and a half to four hour drive from
here. >> okay. Hold on. Let me answer a couple questions
here real quick. Crowder at one point reported that there was
transgender ideology in the bullet cases. Was there anything
that lined up with that? No. And what Steven Crowder did was
he took a field report that hadn't been vetted and he published
it as if it was fact and then he stood behind it. He still has
it pinned because he's a [__]
Right. Everybody was involved with the ATF. The only comment
you had from people who were vaguely involved with the ATF was,
"Hey, that's a field report. That's unreliable. You shouldn't
take that as fact. But Stephen Steven Crowder reported it as
fact because he's a [__] That should be a massive
fine. If you if you publish stuff like that with regards to like
a national tragedy, you publish stuff like that that's wrong.
It should be like a $500,000 fine like immediately or like I
don't know whatever like 30% of your monthly income or something.
50% of your monthly income just immediately gone. It's crazy
that people do this. And he like, as far as I know, still had
it pinned on his on his Twitter like uh when I started the stream
basically.
Let me see. Yeah, still pinned. The misinfo still pinned at the
top of his Twitter. They're making the bulge thing about being
trans. It's about being a furry. It's a weird online like gross,
but
I don't think it's about being trans at all. Uh let's see here.
There was one other question that I wanted to look at. Oh, maybe
not. Yeah, hypers being pror is kind of funny. I do like that
people are trying to read into the video games. They're like
Hell Divers plus I think this guy played Hearts of Iron or something.
It's a little goofy to me. Okay. Where we are right now. And
uh that's that's where where he lived and where he uh they they
turned him in. Please go here.
>> I I can't share any more than what I've already shared.
>> So um we we how we obtained the gun. The gun was found
was found here. Uh so so I I don't have much more details um
on that. Um, we do know that uh that that he drove we had his
car here um on on campus and then and then we had his car going
going south back to back to the St. George. It's actually the
city of Washington in in Washington County. I'm sorry. We don't
have any information that would lead us to believe that. >> Yes.
In fact, it's already it was just released. Yes.
>> We um I can't I can't answer that right
>> Do you feel this is >> uh I I absolutely believe
that this is a watershed in American history. Yes. Um the question
is what kind of watershed and that that chapter remains to be
written. Is this the end of a dark chapter in our history or
the beginning of a darker chapter in our history? We we've look
I I mean if if you look at true political assassinations in this
country of of someone of this stature um this feels a lot like
the late60s um and and having one so gruesomely displayed uh
on camera in all of our hands and in all of our pockets. We are
not wired as human beings biologically historically. We have
not evolved uh in a way that um we are capable of processing
those types of violent imagery. And by the way, we've seen another
one with a gruesome stabbing very recently that went viral. Um
this is not good for us. It is not good to consume. Um social
media is a >> Uh this is not bad >> on our society
right now. And I would encourage again I would encourage people
to log off, turn off, touch grass, hug a family member, go out
and do good in your community. >> Touch grass guys. >> There
are that is happening and it's happening organically right now.
I had a friend in in a small city in Utah who said we're we're
getting together. The Republicans and Democrats in my little
town are getting together to have a discussion tonight. uh last
night um just to find a way to to to find their better angels.
So So yes, this this could be I mean, you know, again, you have
to go back to JFK to to have seen a video live of something like
this happening. Um I wasn't born until 1975, but but I know that
things were really dark in in the late 60s. Sorry to some of
you. I know some of you were there. Uh but but this is the >> this
is uh probably a good point. This is a point that I'm like at
least a little interested in is um this idea that like that's
the probably explains exactly why it's impacting people so much
more, right? Is hey, it's been
a long time since a political assassination has been caught on
camera and never before has it been caught in this much detail.
Like you you can't see this level of detail anywhere else. This
is crazy. >> This is our moment. Um do we escalate or do
we find an off-ramp? And uh again, it's a choice. It's a choice
and every one of us gets to make that choice. Two more questions.
Two more questions right >> Could we clarify that the release
of those host images at 8:00 p.m. timeline director tell gave
us led to the arrest of 10 p.m. for a direct connection between
those two events? I >> I cannot comment if there is a direct
connection or not, but all I can say is that uh that that through
some process the family came to know that this had >> One
more thing. Could you clarify the clothing issue?
>> Was he changing? >> Correct. Yes. Yes. So um so
when he's first spotted on >> Oh, also guys, if you're
on Twitch, if you're following on Twitch right now, if you're
watching on Twitch, I need you to head over to kick. We're going
to kick only for the rest of the stream. Okay, we're hitting
two hours. Heading over to kick only. We'll see you guys over
there in just a little bit. Okay, love you guys. Bye. On to the
kick only portion of the stream. One second.
Boom. Boom. There we go. Give those people like two, three minutes
to switch over real quick. Real real real quick. JFK's was Yeah.
Well, hold on. JFK's was detailed, but you can't see the detail.
Buttniff, that's the difference. You can't see the detail that
Well, you can imagine it. You can read about it and imagine it,
but you can't literally see all of the detail in the same way.
>> On campus, he has different clothing on and then he
changes clothing on the roof and then changed back into that
clothing at some point so that when when he was uh when he was
apprehended when he when he was arrested, um the clothing matched
the clothing he had on before the shooting here at UVU. Last
question here. Yes.
>> Can you tell us a little bit more about >> it
was on camera? It is not in 4K the way Charlie Kirks is. He's
bra. Well, I've never seen uh I've never seen a good transmission
of the JFK stuff then because I've I've literally never seen
I've never seen like a high depth version of it, right? I could
literally count the individual droplets coming out of Charlie
Kirk's neck. I think that's the different thing, right? You could
see his face. You could see every expression. It's entirely different.
Yeah. Shinszo Aab not even close,
>> Yeah. So, um I I >> I don't I don't know why you
guys are pretending that that we have anything akin to this ever.
It's literally literally nothing remotely close. Um you're just
being a contrarian if you think otherwise. >> I don't have
any information on the mental illness part. He was not a student
here at UVU. Um he was living and uh and had lived for a long
time with his family in uh in Washington County in the most part.
Thank you everyone for um for your great work and getting this
information out. I just say process-wise this may be important.
I know many of you aren't familiar with with the process in Utah.
I I think it's important that you understand that. Um basically
um we have 3 days for uh charging documents to be filed. uh CI
will be filed. We'll have more information then, more detailed
information as those charging documents are filed in in preparation
for a preliminary hearing. So, three days. So, you know, we would
anticipate then that that early next week those charging documents
will be filed. We will obviously be working the uh the county
attorney will be working very closely with uh with Mr. Kirk's
family as uh as those documents and decisions are prepared and
made. Thanks everyone. >> All right. Damn. Okay. So, that's
basically everything we got from the press conference. There's
quite a bit there. We've uh people have like gone through social
media and stuff. I don't know if this guy didn't have public
social media. It seems like there's a lot of things missing.
Like there just isn't public social media on this guy uh from
him. Like he I haven't seen anybody going through his social
media. I've seen threads of like social media of his family,
right? And it does seem like they like this family was like tight-knit.
Damn. Okay. How'd this guy have the depth perception to pull
this off? Can somebody explain it? Somebody explain it to me.
I don't know how where the depth perception come from, guys.
I'm just looking through a couple of these pictures of them.
It's just it's like incredibly sad to be honest with you. Look
at a bunch of pictures of them. Like clearly, you know, their
family. They've got this many pictures as a family. It's up.
It's all It's all messed up. I think I've got a a thing of his
like test scores. Oh, no. Not that one. Seen quite a few of these.
But I'm looking for I have something in my docket here with like
his test scores. Oh, that's deleted.
Uh is that just all of it? Oh, here we go. Oh, this is not going
to be the full thing. But apparently he has um this is his ACT
34 math, 32 science, 33 STEM, 34 English, 36 reading. Like apparently
he state rank composite 99th percentile, math 99, science 97,
STEM 99, English 98, reading 100.
Like he is a obviously like a smart kid, right?
Dan says he watched this on so he might have. I don't know. I
just think it's funny how like everybody before any of this any
of the evidence that came out about this guy was out there, people
were just like already inventing evidence to put him on a side.
It's very interesting to me. So, I'm just going through a bunch
of the different pictures. Oh, this was the picture. This is
um he's got a picture of himself riding on Trump's shoulders
apparently
2017 Halloween. This is eight years ago, so quite a bit younger.
Obviously raised it seems like pretty obviously raised Republican.
Pixie said he's a confirmed groper. Yeah, well, you know, I just
let's let's just bet. I just offer everybody to bet on this,
right? Let's just bet. Do you think so? We can bet. It's pretty
easy to bet. I think it's, you know, I
it's not a problem. Um SDL had published some misinfo earlier
about his registration, I believe. So, I wanted to take a look
at this thread. Correcting previous thread. In 2020, a Tyler
Robinson in St. George, Utah, donated $224 to Donald Trump. However,
this is not the Tyler Robinson who just shot Kirk, just someone
with the same name who lived down the street. The shooter Robinson
never donated to any candidate. So yeah, unaffiliated.
As far as I know, unaffiliated, not registered to vote in either
direction,
right? Just unaffiliated and not involved with any specific candidate
or party. Okay. How about instead of money, the loser has to
perform the song of the winner's choosing on your stream? No,
I don't want I want singing on my stream. Didn't vote. This guy's
100% a leftist. You know, you know, might just be the case. See
here. Okay, now we're just on to random memes all over the place.
Okay. Oh. Oh, maybe the Guardian thing was what I was looking
for as well. This is a random classmate, but the Guardian, the
Guardian article I have here is with somebody who interviewed
and said he was his classmate as well. Get the [__]
out of here. So, suspect's high school classmate says Robinson
was the only leftist in a family of very hard Republicans. In
a phone interview on Friday, someone who said they were friends
with Robinson in high school who wanted to remain anonymous said
that the suspect was pretty left on everything and was the only
member of his family that was really leftist. The rest of the
family was very hard Republican. and the friend said around sophomore
year. The friend said Robinson became more extreme in his political
views and would always be just be ranting and arguing about them.
The friend said that they played video games together a lot in
high school and noted that the bullet engraving with the arrows
was a reference to Hell Divers 2, which he mentioned earlier.
He said the arrows specifically were in reference to calling
in a big bomb that exists in the game called the 500 kg. When
the friend saw the news on Friday, he said that he was shocked.
I knew he Robinson had strong political views, but I never thought
it would uh even go near that far. The friend said that he had
not spoken to Robinson in recent years or in years and began
to they began to drift apart toward the end of high school. Another
high school classmate separately told the Guardian that the friend
and Robinson were close in school and would play video games.
I'm guessing this is like a a different classmate said that this
person and Robinson were close. What are you betting for? I'm
just betting that he's not a groper. Um I just think it's pretty
obvious to say that he's like lefting in views. Um I thought
that before I knew this. I think it's just very obvious that
he's like a left-leaning person, but I'm I'm like not 100% sure
and I don't think you need to do anything based on that. I don't
think this is like proof that some leftists like mo most lefty
rhetoric is evil or violent, right? I'm just like, oh, it seems
pretty obvious it's some left-leaning views to me. It seems pretty
obvious. I I also find it very funny that because because it
seems to be like we're leaning lefty with our probability here
that like leftists are just like grabbing onto anything they
can to just throw it back and be like no no no he's he's actually
a griper. He's a griper. I think it's very funny to me. Okay,
because Yeah. See, you're one of the people that's like really
dumb on this and doesn't understand anything. Unless you guys
think this guy was an anti-fascist griper.
Anti-fascist fan. Anti-fascist youth. Awesome. Definitely. Okay.
I I got sent this tweet. This Phil that remains tweet. I don't
even know what this is going to be. Some aerodite tweet the or
some aerodite. I don't know. Short. I don't even know. The rats
are abandoning ship.
>> There's a problem. Yesterday I said that this isn't
the left. It's not us. And it's it's certainly not my left. It's
not any part of the left that I participate in. Did Did
she jump at the beginning of this or hold on?
>> There's a problem.
>> Yesterday I said that this isn't the >> It's not
us. And it's it's certainly not my left. It's not any part of
the left that I participate in, but this is the left. These people
are part of the left. They are staffers. They're in our cohorts.
They're repping Young Democrats of America. They're in our colleges.
They are part of the left and it's a problem.
Around 2016, we made a deal with the devil. We just welcomed
them. >> What do you mean we? You were literally like you're
blissfully unaware of politics in Canada in 2016. What do you
mean we? What do you mean we >> in as liberals? >> What
are you talking about? >> You're one of us. You're just
like us. But they're not. They want to take away property rights
and we don't. They want things and are pursuing something in
many ways antagonistic to what we believe in. And they're the
exact group now reing in the ogre boy. You want to take away
everybody's property and you're going to kill everybody to do
it. Okay, that's what Earight's saying. And what what am I supposed
to do? She's just saying, listen, you guys want to take away
you guys are the violent ones. Yeah, you. It's you. It's all
you. political violence and assassination of Charlie Kirk and
every major political pundant that is left-leaning denounced
the violence. We're overshadowed by this hateful
crowd. >> Ied by this hateful
crowd >> and the left has to reckon with >> hateful
crowd. >> Why Why is she justiculating with her hands
on camera? The the hands are not on camera with this. There's
also something else really insidious going on. The FBI came out,
I didn't go back far enough. >> We're overshadowed, hands
aren't on camera, hateful
crowd, and the left has to reckon with this. There's also something
else really insidious going on. The FBI came out today in talking
about the Charlie Kirk case, saying that they are being inundated
with bots from China and from Russia, particularly on social
media, spreading misinformation
and inciting violence. It is time for the silent majority to
actually speak up. I'm not Serite. If you want to hear more from
the silent majority, like >> Good. The rats are abandoning
ship
Uh I do find it funny that it's like guys, guess what? A tragedy
happened and the per the people we need to blame are the exact
people I've been railing against for the past year. The exact
people I've said we need to cut out for the past year. It's it's
guess what guys? There's a tragedy and it's their fault, obviously.
Amazing.
Is every group the silent majority? Um because people hate that
Trump is so great at branding. People don't ever want to admit
where they get their stuff from and then they'll copy this guy
completely. They'll have no new ideas of their own and they'll
go, "You know what? This is our this is our message now, guys.
We're just going to be Trump. We're just going to be Trump. Actually,
we're the silent majority." Oh,
hey, Timcast. Your boy is lying about me because it's personal
apparently. We have never met or spoken. Want to facilitate the
first chat and see what he's so mad about? Hey, notite. The moderate
left that you claim to be part of has spent years calling people
like Charlie. The moderate calls us the moderates call us. So
the extremist will do something like this about us and they can
claim their hands are clean. The moderate left wasn't calling
him. Tankies were uh your non-tanky one-time business partner
called him Satan spawn. Care to comment?
Rob no.
Rob no is like the rock. Okay. He just took his elbow pad off.
He just took his elbow pad off. He's pointing in either direction.
Oh my god. He's going to It's the people's elbow
directly to not soight's head. She can't have any more concussions.
Rob, what are you doing? Rob, no. Rob, you have to stop. Rob.
Rob, please. Rob, we can't do it
This is the the signaling of like guys, I was never attached
to the person who did call for who did absolutely amp the rhetoric
as much as they possibly could. Yeah, that that person. That
person. No, no, no. Scroll down two messages. Wait, are you talking
about Wait, hold on. Scroll down two messages. Wait, what are
you looking for? Canadian caller.
This one. Then why are tens of thousands of hundreds of thousands
of seemingly moderate left liberals cheering on this assass his
assassination if they didn't think it this one? Okay. What is
this? Get the [__] out of here. No way. No way. She
didn't. Satan spawn is not the same as Lol. Yeah, it's literally
worse. It's It's literally It is actually worse. I don't know
if you know this, but like Satan is the root of evil. They're
not the same thing. Are we not allowed to just express disdain
for people now? Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
Satan is misunderstood. Give him a break. Uh-huh. Dude, people
are wild and wild it out on the Twitter timeline. Okay, the the
like mental gymnastics people have been going to with all of
this stuff. All of this stuff has just been crazy to me. Okay,
this is another dude we watched. I actually had this pulled up,
but >> cool with this. >> Check this out. This guy
says he went to school with Tyler Robinson. I don't know if we
have any confirmation of this, but I'm going to let it play in
full. Okay, 57 seconds. We're let this guy cook. This is his
moment. >> Tyler Robinson kid. I'll show y'all. That's
him right there. Tyler Robinson. I'm not sure. >> Never
mind. He shows a yearbook. Okay. >> Chase, make this [__]
>> Wait, hold on. Let's Let's confirm that. Tyler Robinson
third. Oh, that's clearly him. Class 2021. Where are you, though?
Who are >> Tyler Robinson. I'm not trying to like clout
Chase make this about me, but uh I'm not going to say I knew
this kid really well. I didn't know him very well at all, but
I definitely saw him for like three straight years in high school.
And the best way I could describe him is just
like a Reddit kid. I don't know. I feel like if you were in high
school that same time and even probably now like 2018 and then
like you know those kinds of kids, but that's exactly what he
was. >> He's a Freddy kid. >> All I'm going to say
is this is the kind of [__] that happens when you
spend way too much time online and all of a sudden your beliefs
are all the way this way or all the way this way and you do some
dramatic to please these people that are a kid dog. >> This
internet is seriously no joke, >> dude. Hold on. Tell me
that you guys don't see it. Is this guy like white redneck? Oh,
sorry. Like redneck Mormon
>> Do you hear it in the voice? >> And the best way
I could describe him is
>> it's Shuy >> like a Reddit kid. I don't know.
I feel like if you were in high school around that same time
and even probably now like 2018 and >> the eyes, the mustache,
the voice. This is just Mormon shoe, dude. That's crazy. All
right.
Well, thank you for the update, Mormon Shouy. All right. We got
two different thing. We've got the guy. >> So, my name
>> Why can't I remember this dude's name now? Hunter Kak.
But he's got a name that I knew him by and I I lost it. I remembered
it when I saw it the other day and now I've like totally lost
his name. What's What's this guy's creator name? He He did collabs
with No, it's not this. Staxiums. Staxiums.
Staxiums. Did an interview with Channel Fives 40 minutes. I don't
think I would have quite checked that out yet. All right,
I'm going to do We're going to do the Nick Fentes Matt Walsh
bridge being
What? So, Matt Walsh posted this today, which is so out of character
for him. It's crazy. All right, but we'll get into why cuz I
think there's a clip in the replies that actually explains why.
Unsurprisingly, the left is gearing up to pin this on Nick Fentes
by claiming the killer was a groper. Unfortunately for them,
that claim doesn't fit any of the facts on the ground. Not that
they give a damn about that. The killer labeled Kirk a fascist.
That is the ter that is a term only ever used by the left as
an insult to the right. The idea that he Charlie for not being
right-wing enough, but also consider Charlie a fascist is totally
incoherent. Absolute nonsense.
This is my thing. Like it just seems like totally incoherent
that you would call Fentes or sorry you call Charlie Kirk a fascist
and like uh try to leave that kind of political messaging behind.
Right. Goripers called Kirk a fascist all the time. Where? Where?
Where? Butt sniff. You have you can't you have to back this up
now. Okay. You have to back it up. Don't respond with anything
else. Just respond with links to Gropers calling Charlie Kirk
a fascist or Fuentes calling Charlie Kirk a fascist. Yeah, literally
anything. Oh, wait. Never mind. You only care if Fentes says
it on stream. Well, I would need an actual griper who has any
real tie to the movement and not just some random calling him
a fascist. But go ahead, show me some random calling him a fascist.
And let me see. It's incredible that they have the nerve to celebrate
this for 48 hours and then go, "Oh, but it wasn't us, by the
way." Um, this is just tying people together. Fentes says, "Thank
you. Thank you for saying something about this, Matt. It shows
a lot of integrity. These people have no shame. I'm looking for
I'm looking for this one." Bro, you work for Ben Shapiro. Hold
on. This is an awesome clip. Get back to work, Matt Walsh. Get
back to work. Do not criticize Israel. Oh, yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Yes, sir. Ben,
>> that same guy's like, "Hey, Matt, thanks for doing that.
You got a lot of integrity." Okay, you got a lot of integrity,
buddy. Oh, goofy stuff. Very funny, but very goofy.
H, amazing. So, yeah. I just I Dude, I don't I don't understand.
Oh, I I closed the tweet. Whoops. I don't understand where this
is coming from. I don't get it at all.
And unfortunately, Howling Newton's the guy who's like actually
saying the intelligent things about this, right? Yashar Ali posts
uh authorities so first authorities in Utah have released the
booking photos of Tyler Robinson the 22-year-old suspect who
was arrested late last night in the assassination of Charlie
Kirk. Authorities notably did not reveal why Tyler Robinson hated
Charlie Kirk. They just said he hated him and have gotten and
had gotten more political in recent years. A reminder that Charlie
was hated by a wide variety of people including who believed
he was a tool for Israel and the anti-fascist engravings mean
nothing if they don't match with the rest of his ideology and
communications. Okay. Where are the communication the other communications
that tell us he's a um where his ideology? Where's the other
communications that this would conflict
Yeah, you have to say things that actually comport with reality.
Dude, I don't what why would a have anti-fascist slogans. It's
like the best people could go with is he did it as a misdirection.
Okay. I bruh bruh. One more mutant tweet. One more. Oh, this
slazic guy. Um there are two possibilities from there. Okay.
Charlie Kirk shooter shooter uh shooters bullet casings had the
following messages in graves. All of these there's two likely
possibilities from there. Woke. Don't think so personally given
the usage of gay as an
Uh-huh. By the way, lots of people are anti-fascist who aren't
woke. Do we have to go back to H specifically? By the way, by
the way, uh I'll go into this in a little bit. 764/order
of nine angles skitso. And good luck explaining any of that to
the general public.
Oh, these are not the only two options, bro. I And I just want
you guys to know that I thought the um I thought the right-winger
thing was honestly like a better example early on. Or I I thought
that was a more like a better theory, dude. Yeah, exactly. Bito.
Yeah, he's smart enough to do this, guys. This guy's really smart.
He's like the kind of teeth do this for sure. Gropers would love
to do this. They'd love to pin this on leftists because of the
Bella Chow me message. Well, the Bellachow thing is anti-fascist.
It's really not just um Hassan. It's like anti-fascist. It's
it's almost it's bordering on non ideological just anti-fascist,
right? It is an anti-fascist anthem for people who are standing
up to the in different countries. Like I think it comes from
Italy, but it's like standing up against fascists in general.
But I would say in America, the left are the only people who
really engage in the anti-fascist rhetoric. And but I don't think
it's just Asan. There are a lot of people further left of his
like actual Marxist Leninists who could this guy could have been
close to. And listen, I there's no strong There's no strong proof
either way, but I'll show the picture. Okay, I'll show the picture.
Uh do we have do we have this? Oh, I don't have this. Wait, what?
I put it in my Discord. Give me a second. Let me find this picture.
This is uh there's a couple different things from Hos's Discord,
Hos's like uh
community and stuff. And people were throwing this around like
they think there it it wasn't there was no definitive proof at
all. Okay, except people saying this guy was in anti-fascist
Discords. There's no proof at all, but um Drewie, you could show
it's in one Groper war playlist ever. You can show it's in one,
right? But show me the actual people who message me for Groper
saying it or using the song or anything like that, right? You
got to show me that. You can't show me one playlist because I
can show you H and a bunch of other leftists loving this song.
I can literally show you evidence of that, right? Yeah, Bellachow
is a banger. Okay, it is. But H is like, "Oh, we actually aren't
going to uh we're not going to talk about this anymore." We've
always had a firm and clear policy on following to, but I am
instituting a new rule due to recent events. All mention and
discourse over the recent events is absolutely banned here. Mods
have been working overtime to ban people recklessly memeing about
such things. So, so to save us effort, I am simply banning the
topic altogether. Zero tolerance. I'm not joking when I think
when I say I think there's a real chance that he was in some
of these kinds of discords. Yeah, I really do. Hos was just very
recently doing the Bellachchow song twice. I think twice in the
past like 20 30 days. H was playing the Bellachchow song to start
his stream. It's It's not definitive. It's not anything. I'm
just saying that like that's probably where I'd lean is in that
like Marxist Leninist
uh communist anti-fascist zone is where where I would lean personally.
Maybe it's in your Discord. Maybe. Who knows? Probably not. All
right. I think I've gotten through basically all of the Twitter
messages on stuff like this. Kami tank. If he was a commie tanky,
we would know already, but who knows this extremist most of the
time and make their extremist their whole personality. So I would
well he just we haven't found found like anything in terms of
his actual political ideology, which is weird, right? Like I
can't find a single thing on what this guy believed. The closest
I've found or the closest I've seen is somebody replying to me.
Um I did a perfect tweet to uh upset people by the way. Hold
on. Where is it? Where is it? Here. Who's this one?
A lot of people mad about this one. Okay. But somebody So somebody
posted this and then there's another one. Is it maybe under the
first tweet or under my own reply?
Nope. There's somebody posted like a this one. They said apparently
this is him. Now I can't see any proof this is him. So where
was this where was this photo posted? Yeah. I I've never seen
this. So I don't know where this photo was posted. But this this
picture is also fake. Like this this picture there's no Trump
logo on this picture out of left field guess. He's a Candace
Owens enjoyer, maybe. I just I can't believe we haven't found
this guy. Like, I can't believe there aren't people who recognize
this guy now from from like Discord and are posting his logs
somewhere. That just seems so unlikely to me. It seems kind of
crazy. All right, what else do we got here? Am I missing anything
big that happened today? I don't think I'm missing anything.
I think I' I'm up to the moment now. I think I've got every important
fact out,
right? Can anybody think of something that's that's been missed
that you feel like was really important to this conversation?
Cuz I can switch. We could go back to drama. We could do a bunch
of other stuff. I've got other content tonight. I just want to
make sure I'm I'm through all of this stuff. There's another
photo of Tyler before the shooting. If that's another stupid
meme that is not at all a photo of him, I'm going to time you
up for the rest of the night. Junar Arc, just so you know. Let
me click on it. Yeah, it's just that guy. Yeah. Okay. You did
that already. That's the second time you've done it. You come
back tomorrow. Good luck. Hours. We'll do 20 hours. You can be
here at the start of the stream tomorrow. Good luck, buddy. Covered
Discord's response. Nope. No, we don't have a good indication
of this at all. Oh, that's cool. Is easy to be honest. I really
don't respect any of the people on that panel. So, it's like
very difficult to really want to go watch it. I'll just be real
with you. I'll just be real with you, man. I just I respect nobody
on that panel. So, it's like it's lost its luster entirely to
me. Yeah. Okay. I Man, if we don't have anything else, somebody
asked if I saw the Discord response. I've not seen that yet.
Uh Discord Tyler Robinson.
Yeah, I don't see anything. Suspect alleging to learn more about
the suspect in the shooting. This is 22-year-old Tyler Robinson.
Authorities say that Robinson used the social media platform
Discord to send messages about the rifle and the ammunition that
was used in the shooting. And so for more on these messages and
really a breakdown of Discord, we bring in our next guest to
help break it all down, Jennifer Graham with Desireette News.
Great to have you on. a lot of fastmoving parts to this story
and I think a lot of people are interested in this Discord aspect.
>> Yeah, it it's an interesting platform and one that >> Dude,
I think uh I think a lot of the discussion around Discord is
just people knowing that it's like a grooming platform at this
point. >> A lot of people don't know much about because
it's really for the youngest Americans. It's it's not your father's
social media platform, so to speak. >> Yeah. So, if you
could just for our viewers break down what this what this platform
is. >> Oh, I know. I don't care. I don't need to see I
don't need to hear boo boomers do this. I forgot we uh we have
the Staxiums interview. Let's watch the Channel 5 Staxiums interview.
I'm going to use the bathroom. I'm going to get a little water
and